[Musique]
dire que Jean-Michel Aulas à l'ambition
chevillée au corps s'est enfoncé une
porte ouverte sur le chemin de l'âme en
effet comment tu imaginer une telle
réussite sans une mobilisation de chaque
instant une audace inouïe une
obstination forcenée une puissance de
travail hors du commun et malgré tout
une intuition sans faille qui ne va pas
sans un petit coup de pouce du destin
d'abord en réussissant à transformer une
minuscule officine informatique CJ créé
en 1983 en un groupe puissant et
rentable de même réussira-t-il en 1987
l'introduction en bourse avec l'aide de
luitenberger de ce qui est devenu depuis
une des toutes premières sociétés
informatique de gestion en Europe
chiffre d'affaires 225 millions d'euros
Jean-Michel Aulas tenait sa première
revanche sur des origines modestes
hazard peut-être mais ce n'est pas sûr
c'est en effet la même année qu'il
devenait le président de l'Olympique
Lyonnais à l'époque le club est au bord
de la banqueroute et se morfon en
deuxième division et c'est dans l'avion
de Bernard Tapie qu'il prenait sa
décision venue de je connais la suite
l'homme cultive le secret avec ferrocité
il est volontiers distant et cassant
capable de rendre coup pour coup à ses
ennemis qui sont nombreux mais il est
aussi capable d'être ému jusqu'aux
larmes parce que son fils est absent à
la remise de sa Légion d'honneur en fait
toute réussite hors norme conserve une
par un sondage de mystère celle de
Jean-Michel Aulas ne dérange pas la
règle
[Musique]